what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
all right there is a story there's a
story where deadpool becomes venom now
this story is miss stories written by
Rick Remender and it is a descent into
absolute madness partly because of the
fact that on its mass Pesce deadpool is
wearing a mustache I don't know how that
works but apparently it does now this
story also picks up in 1985 now that the
kicker about all this is that this
treats secret worse - as if it never
really ended right I mean when when Jim
shooter wrote Secret Wars 1 and it was
just this mysterious being called the
Beyonder that took all the villains and
all the heroes and it put him on battle
world and it made him fight each other
you know when this story first popped up
in 1984 was all the rage was like yeah
this is crazy this is awesome you know
it was meant to be a one-off but because
of his popularity Marvel launched Secret
Wars number two which basically gave
expansion on the Dianna the Beyonder you
know it's curious about humanity showed
up on earth and looked like John
Travolta from Saturday Night Fever so
what ended up happening is in this story
the Beyonder never left
the Beyonder was never defeated by the
molecule man Owen Reese instead the
Beyonder was the Beyonder was messing
around with people now Deadpool is
contracted by Galactus and the reason
why he's contracted by Galactus is
because the Beyonder merged MODOK with
the butt of Galactus
I don't know else I don't know how else
to say that like I don't know how else
to to say that to you guys but the idea
here is a Galactus basically contracts
or at least he gives Deadpool the the
retcon expunge of fire and says your job
is to go after the Beyonder and
basically use the retcon
expunge a fire to annihilate him from
existence and of course we know the
expended fire is basically like a
stand-in for the ultimate nullifier
right like the ultimate nullifier can
obliterate things from existence well
the retcon expunge a fire removes things
from continuity so it's basically it
treats the Beyonder like he never
existed is essentially what happened the
problem with this is that when deadpool
finds the Beyonder
he's just totally enamored by hey he's
totally enamored by his Jheri curls
merely as Jerry curls are absolutely
incredible and because of that Deadpool
can't let it go not only that for some
reason or another Deadpool has jheri
curl now which is whoa which is weird
but the funny thing about this too is
apparently the Beyonder took Billy ocean
and made him his limo driver now for
those of you guys who don't know Billy
ocean was a guy who did the the
Caribbean your Caribbean Queen song you
know now we're sure you know like he did
he's the one that did that song and
apparently the Beyonder loved it so much
that he made Billy ocean his driver but
there's also another reason why he
brought in Billy ocean the reason for
this is keep in mind this basically
treats the events of secret Wars like
they actually happened in the sense that
Peter Parker eventually came across the
Venom symbiote at not knowing what it
was thinking it was a suit it bonded to
Peter Parker and he came back to earth
with his new costume
of course being a superhero he
immediately attached the Beyonder and of
course is like look you know you made me
who I am you basically made me this
venom character but then we realized the
other reason why Billy Billy ocean is
here is that in addition to being one of
the most famous singers of all times uh
he is he's very good at killing people
and what he basically what he basically
does he this is Rick Remender man quick
Remender writes this line where he says
hey spider-man get into my dreams and
out of my car now this is basically a
flip on the phrase on the song the Billy
ocean did raise like you know get out of
my dreams and into my bed like that's
basically that that's the song they're
playing on kind I love this - I love
this story the crazy thing about this
though with regards to venom becoming a
I'm sorry Deadpool becoming venom
because of the fact that Peter Parker is
basically blasted with the you know this
weapon whatever it is that the Billy
ocean's using that the singer Billy
oceans using ah the Venom symbiote casts
off of Peter Parker and in response it
merges itself to a Deadpool now at this
point we basically pick up like we
literally just jumped forward to 1993
and the be honors been living like this
wild life is ridiculously fun life but
but the novelties were off not only that
and man do recommenders cold-blooded
this one not only that Tony Stark is a
full-blown alcoholic like the the his
whole alcoholism has gotten the best of
him and there is
there is this really messed up line
where Deadpool's like what happened to
the retcon expunged afire you know
whatever happened to that because I
still have to kill the Beyonder and Tony
Stark says we pawned it we've haand it
with the room with the rest of my Iron
Man suit and then he says he kept the
glove he's still iron man he's still in
control this is this is this is kind of
offensive to be honest I've known
alcoholics it's kind of offensive
alcoholics but it's also Tony Stark and
it's a Deadpool comic so it's I guess
take it for what it's worth but what is
up happening here is Deadpool basically
says okay fine you know if we don't have
the record expunged of fire then I'm
basically gonna be a good guy and so
what he does is he basically sells he
sells Tony Stark to advanced idea
mechanics he literally sells Tony Stark
and I guess they're gonna take his brain
and they're gonna do whatever is they do
I don't think we ever find out but from
here he basically goes on this trip to
try to become a superhero by joining
different groups of course he goes to
the Fantastic Four and Reed Reed
Richards says we do not hire curly
haired people which of course is one of
the most severe instances of
discrimination that I've ever seen uh he
goes to the Avengers mansion and Jarvis
chases him off with a broom and then he
go
he goes to the defenders got the
defenders suck he goes to the defenders
and the defenders are desperate they're
like you ready the doorbell all the
defenders we're hiring please and he's
like nope he doesn't want to work with
the defenders no one likes the defenders
that's but that's messed up yeah that's
old-school to finish I'm pretty sure the
new Marvel now 2.0 defenders will be
pretty amazing but in the end like the
yo Deadpool looks random basically says
the problem the reason why he's not able
to find gainful employment is because of
the fact that the Venom symbiote exists
in the form of jheri curl on his head
now this is ridiculous this is when Rick
Remender
well if the comic hadn't gone off the
rails before it goes off the rails now
like this is when Rick Remender really
just kind of loses it and the reason why
is because you know it seems like the
Deadpool does not have the Venom
symbiote but he still has the powers of
spider-man I don't know how I don't know
how that works but it does and so what
he says is okay look you know if no
one's gonna take me on as a superhero
then I'm gonna be my own superhero and
he essentially just goes around killing
people like that's what he does he just
kills criminals everywhere that he finds
them not only that we find out that the
Beyonder has basically reinvigorated the
battleworld concept in the sense that
instead of like traditional superheroes
you know fighting against crime instead
they're all basically just fighting
against each other in this giant battle
royale now when Deadpool gets there
Rick Remender starts making making fun
of comic book fans he makes fun of you
he makes fun of me but he makes fun to
come up with fans there's this guy I
guess he's super something I don't know
the century or something like that well
there's this guy that appears to to
Deadpool basically says you look
ridiculous in that costume that guy over
there is wearing an American flag and
he's got an American flag discus that
guy is an iconic hero and then the
response of Deadpool is like hey look
man I mean that doesn't really matter I
mean the suit doesn't really matter you
know I mean you have like that guy over
there who's basically midnight you know
he's just as good as Captain America or
something on those lines but then like
this weird superhero just like freaks
out this is Wonder commander starts
making fun of fans because he's like you
do not take superheroes on the street
and put them on teams with big
superheroes Street superheroes stay in
their place big team superhero stay in
their place you can't allow things to
mix because if you allow things to mix
and it makes it different and things
that are different are weird and I don't
understand it and I get confused and I
don't like it and it's it's it's him
making fun of comic book fans basically
saying comic book fans don't like change
like Hollywood fans are scared of change
because it may put them in a position
where they're not comfortable as they
come a book fan I don't consider that to
be the case but I think it's also pretty
funny like it's pretty hilarious but the
fact remains here that we basically pick
up you know we pick up with Jerry
Springer this comic is insane we pick up
with Jerry Springer and apparently we
have Deadpool we have some chick with
the Venom symbiote hair now with a jheri
curl and then would he have the Beyonder
and they're here because of the fact
that this girl who's calling herself the
carnage girl is with the Beyonder and
Deadpool's upset about a Deadpool is
angry just because of the fact that this
girl caused him so much hassle the
reason why was because Deadpool's goal
was to invite the Beyonder over to his
house for grand gala and the goal was to
just basically kill the Beyonder the
issue with this is that the Beyonder
brought his ex-girlfriend brought
Deadpool his ex-girlfriend with him and
his ex-girlfriend
apparently carnage Crowe is just like
this crazy chick that like burned his
house down that like dropped a deuce in
his home I mean it was it was it was
really messed up but uh in the end like
she basically says look I'm with the
Beyonder now you have to show me some
respect
and when Deadpool's like why she says
because I'm pregnant
now the reason why this is ridiculous is
because if you guys didn't watch Jerry
Springer back in the day it was like the
big huge drop it was like man like you
know this guy's been cheating on me or
something like that or this girl's been
cheating on me or it's just like some
ridiculous situation and then like the
mic drop moment is like I'm pregnant
and it's just it's it's like oh my god
well did we find out that apparently the
Beyonder is not the father of this child
the father of this child is glad it's
the plot thickens Galactus fathered like
he basically slept with beyonders
girlfriend in order to get his revenge
on the Beyonder merging MODOK with his
butt and so because of this the two of
them just get into a massive fight and
the earth is destroyed now from here
Rick Remender is like whatever hashtag
logic we end up picking up with Deadpool
having saved the world and the reason
why is because on the fight between
Galactus and the beyond or Deadpool was
just like all right you guys are losing
your minds you guys are way too powerful
to be fighting like this you're gonna
give it a wipe everything out of
existence
he used the retcon expunge a fire to
obliterate them from continuity and so
the world celebrated Deadpool they were
like yeah Deadpool save the world
Deadpool is amazing well the problem
with this is that in the mind of
Deadpool he's been seeking admiration
this entire time he's been seeking
people to look at him and believe that
he is the best he's the best superhero
the greatest of all the superheroes the
issue with this is that you still have
superheroes around it and so Deadpool is
not getting everyone's adoration instead
you know they're they're celebrating
Thor they're celebrating Captain America
so on a saw forth and so what Deadpool
decides to do is kill for it's the most
logical thing apparently for Deadpool to
do and so he goes so when Thor's using
the bathroom
Deadpool runs up on him he grabs his
hammer he kills for he basically becomes
Deadpool venom Thor and then kills all
the superheroes except for the women
that he considers to be attractive so
that they can admire how attractive
attractive he is and so on the problem
with this is that he's basically just
become a dick like that's what he is
he's basically like yes I'm the greatest
person in the world you all should
worship me but it's funny because he's
having this conversation with Doc Samson
and doc Samson is like no usually when
it comes to something like this or
people say that nobody respects them or
they're causing drama or something like
that they usually do things like causing
drama because it makes them feel like
they're achieving something when they're
not but he also says that the reason why
people don't like you before was because
you were a dick I mean you could say
sure like they just didn't respect you
you were a small-time superhero or you
were really more of an antihero more
than anything else but it was really
just because you were a jerk and no one
liked you and so in response deadpool
rips off the head of doc Sampson goes
and grabs the record expunged afire and
like retcons the story out of continuity
that's basically that's how Rick
Remender exits this story essentially
doesn't exist and Marvel Comics seems to
be the case this story is insane but I
love it I love this story where Deadpool
becomes venom because it's so ridiculous
because it's so insane and I think that
every once in a while we have to read
crazy insane comics because they help to
keep us grounded it's like it's like
sci-fi movies right like sometimes you
just got to sit down and you got to
watch Frankenfish not because
Frankenfish is a good movie not because
the city were close to what anybody
could even consider to be anything
remotely near a good movie but because
of the fact that you you just need
things like that it's like that with
everything right I mean you got to play
games like Call of Duty so you can play
the bad and you could appreciate the
good you play Call of Duty like man I
really like battlefield or if you hate
battlefield you play Call of Duty you
say I play battlefield so I can
appreciate Call of Duty whatever the
case may be like you got to have
everything in balance you know and I
love the way this whole thing this whole
thing comes out but the fact remains if
you guys are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like I'm sure there's gonna be a
few people who take themselves too
seriously or like you were laughing in
the video and I don't like it but uh
anything of it guys we're gonna bring
this to an end and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]